what's going on guys so last year we did
a pretty awesome episode called
mind-blowing movie Easter eggs where we
showcase some of the little nuggets that
are hidden away in some of your favorite
movies then we asked you to tell us what
are some of the Easter eggs that we
didn't include what are some of the
Easter eggs that we left hidden in the
bushes and you responded
thanks now we present to you by blowing
movie Easter eggs part two chosen by you
what do you say we kick it off with the
undisputed king of Easter eggs Pixar
last time we pointed out that every
Pixar film contains a nod to the next
one but then you guys flooded our inbox
asking us to talk about the secret code
that's in every Pixar movie a113
what is this mysterious code is it a
secret bus Locker and Grand Rapids
Michigan is it a shout-out to the
Illuminati or could it be the
coordinates to where Walt Disney's
frozen head lies actually a113 refers to
a classroom in the animation department
at Cal arts whose alumni includes Pixar
bigwigs John Lasseter and Brad Bird
among others and you know what a 1:1
three doesn't just pop up and Pixar
movies it's also popped up in The
Simpsons The Hunger Games Mission
Impossible 4 The Avengers the list goes
on and on and on pretty cool but I do
kind of wish the coordinates where you
could find Walt Disney's frozen head
another thing you flooded our comments
section with are all the Easter eggs
contained within the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and we could spend hours just
sitting here listing them and some of
you already have
get a life I'm kidding look what we're
doing but the most obscure Marvel Easter
Egg is probably one that you've never
seen in an alternate opening to the
Incredible Hulk there lies the frozen
body of Captain America a bit of a reach
so it's no secret that George Lucas and
Steven Spielberg have man crushes on
each other but it goes a step further in
Indiana Jones Raiders of the Lost Ark
r2d2 and c3po are on the wall in the
Well of Souls George Lucas to his credit
returned the favor in the prequels when
he stashed a pod full of ETS in the
Imperial Senate those prequels not my
faves
everybody has been obsessed with Batman
vs Superman since the news about it
dropped at Comic Con 2013 but let's go
back to 2007 Will Smith's I am Legend
featured this little dance
was it like a twinkle in somebody's eye
that this was gonna happen or was it
maybe just like a tip of the hat to
something they thought would never
happen either way it's happening and I
gotta say Zack Snyder do not screw this
up it's all I have
my favorite Martin Scorsese film is
Goodfellas but he won the Oscar for the
department departed fun fact every time
a character is about to get killed
there's an ex prominently displayed on
the screen
take a peek yeah there's one
Leo fat Damon look out Jack Nicholson
look out character actor I don't know
there's also a rumor if you turn up the
volume real loud you can hear Martin
Scorsese himself saying I love you leo
you're the only actor for me last time
we pointed out the head girl writes
Shaun of the Dead summarized the entire
plot of the movie in the first 15
minutes well guess what
he did it again in the World's End when
Simon Pegg recounted the glory days of
his youth there was drinking that was
fun there was controversy there were
ladies there were shots there was drama
of course there was drinking nine pints
in and it was us against the world
things got mental in the Beehive so we
repaired to the bowls club or as we like
to call it of the smokehouse I remember
sitting up there blood on my knuckles
beer down my shirt sick on my shoes
seeing the orange glow of a new dawn
break and knowing in my heart life would
never feel this good again
so basically Edgar Wright spoils every
movie he makes in the first 15 minutes
not cool Edgar knock it off
so what did we leave out what Easter
eggs are out there on the lawn that we
did not pick up and put in our basket
let us know in the comments section
below and who knows maybe in a little
while we're gonna do movie Easter eggs
number three this episode is brought to
you by best fun
where you can experience the best in
Ultra HD TVs check out the sweepstakes
link in the description below and enter
for a chance to win an amazing Ultra HD
TV from screen junkies I want to thank
you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter by my team you see it
slowly occur to him that it looks like
Milhouse and it's just really funny to
watch an animated character come to a
slow realization and then he's like
looks just like you're Poindexter hahaha